so when a game so when a game called
goat simulator makes ten male over ten
million dollars you know there's going
to be other ones and here we are bear
simulator
I can't wait to have my new bear I have
the choice to say nah but that's that'd
be a shitty video
okay let's I'm sorry I don't mean to
start this video off being all like they
oh my god I have college best game ever
okay so we're in a cave oh I can sprint
a [ __ ] look at this whoa
I am a fast bag be a bear complete I got
an itchy it's just a maggot
smack it it's very awkward liquid coming
from it and I don't know why I keep
doing this
I can sleep but no we got to go
adventuring so what can a bear do in the
bear world
I'm a bear bird and a bird no that
doesn't make sense
okay Oh our first me a duck landed I
love how we walk like this every night
it shag em close em ah [ __ ] yo [ __ ] god
I hate ducks anyway I'm a bear what else
can be fine
Oh more ducks blemish [ __ ] upon how do
you kill a duck come here little bunny
i'ma [ __ ] you up [ __ ] oh I slap your
ass hey that's that's that's good that's
pretty good what else can we find it is
a really empty game
I mean what the [ __ ] is this
we got a pizza there it is a veggie
pizza oh god damn it all right fine you
had a couple of slices excuse me that
was the whole pizza you're not fooling
anyone with your diet bear you can't
attack and run at the same time so I
don't really my coordination skills are
awful
I didn't know they were that bad look at
this how am I supposed to attack so you
have to wait for the rabbit to get stuck
oh wow the AI in this game is truly
amazing
I really feel emerged in this nature
landscape let's go to someone's home see
if they want to drink tea no there this
is just a homeless shelter awesome
I am their dangerous
mammal alive I like the FaceCam note
there's no fishes I thought they'd be
fishes because that's what Barrett
Pharisees [ __ ] me I guess pizzas make
more sense so far this game sucks we are
now entering Shepherd lake this is all
too exciting Oh a new level Wow Wow
okay what do we got here though there's
no humans so far we got an actual battle
going here bear versus Fox hello red
foxy boo I don't want to fight you
you could be my friend what is your name
you are acting as if I'm not right in
front of you with my hands stretched out
ready to hug you giving you a good old
bear hunt you want a hug is that oh I
see which
oh it's attacking me with this vicious
backwards attack I don't think we're
gonna live this so I'm just gonna try
and escape and we died from a fox a bear
a bear died from a fox
bravo Bravo me and Bravo Game Developers
you've done it now okay so we respawn in
our house as if nothing happened okay
well more exploring this is really fun
I'm having at the time of my life I mean
honestly this game is a piece of [ __ ]
the more I play it the more I realize it
this video is now a PSA of like don't
buy this game it's not funny you know
maybe your intention was to play as a
bear but it's still [ __ ] like it's not
even good at that this game is not
finished there's no way this game can be
finished there's nothing to do in the
game I can't believe it I feel like I'm
missing something this is ridiculous I
thought it would be I could make like a
funny video out of this but it's so bad
what am I missing
it's got 9 out of 10 on Steam very
positive oh my god ok so this game was
kick-started and it turned out it got
like a hundred K and this is what they
came up with
holy [ __ ] they got a hundred K holy [ __ ]
shame on you
okay so I think it's pretty clear what
we need to do
all right I want a refund
[ __ ] sake I can't even refund it alright
thank you so much for watching leave
like be enjoyed and hopefully next game
we play it's gonna be a little bit more
interesting but that's it for me for now
and as always stay awesome press far J
Studios what are you doing I eat come
out of there Jimmy when you [ __ ] yeah
for my secret sleep baby back